yep thank you very much it's a great
pleasure and honor for me to be actually
at Berkeley this semester and being
hosted by this geometry of polynomials
where I'm learning much more than I'm
giving but it's quite a fascinating
subject and I will mention it at one
point in connection with this lecture
the title of my lecture is randomness in
number theory but in many of the fliers
that was announced the limits of proof
so I will try accommodate both I know
very little about the limits of proof
but my adviser Paul Cohen knew quite a
lot so let me start with him and I'll
quickly get past that and at that point
anybody who really wants to see about
limits of proof might want to leave as I
say in the airline's if you aren't on
the flight to San Francisco Mart now
might be a good time to leave I'll tell
you when to leave okay so I want to pull
current two years before he passed away
he wrote a paper on Scotland's method
and the pessimism about proofs in
mathematics and he writes a number it's
a short paper but let me read it out to
you the key relevant points he certainly
was interested in the theory of numbers
in the second half of his life and he
says with like we reach a contradiction
is explaining Scotland's method and
thereby prove something but suppose one
asks an unnatural statement about primes
such as the twin prime question I'll
return to what that is in the lecture
perhaps on the basis of statistical
statistical considerations we expect the
primes to satisfy this law but the prime
seem rather random and in order to prove
that the statistical hypothesis is true
we have to find some logical law that
implies it is it not very likely that
simply as a random set of numbers the
primes do satisfy their hypothesis and
then he continues explaining about
limits of proof and he says therefore my
conclusion is the following I believe
that the vast majority of statements
about integers are totally and
permanently beyond proof in any
reasonable system and that would include
allowing more axioms so getting around
girdle's incompleteness theorem
here I'm using proof in the sense that
mathematicians use the word say is being
somewhat vague can statistical evidence
be regarded as proof I would like to
have an open mind and say why not if the
first ten billion zeros of the zeta
function I'll define it today lie on the
line whose real part is equal to 1/2
what conclusion shall we draw
I feel incompetent even to speculate how
future generations will regard numerical
evidence of this kind in this
pessimistic spirit I may conclude by
asking if we are witnessing the end of
the era of pure proof began so
gloriously by the Greeks I hope that
mathematics lives for a very long time
and that it does not reach that dead end
for many years to come so that's quite a
donna and if you want to leave now then
I will return to it at the end I'm going
to talk about randomness and he's
already raised two questions that I'm
we're dear to him and are dear to me the
twin prime problem and the Riemann
hypothesis and both are intimately
connected with randomness as I want to
try explain all right so I'm the thing
I'm trying to contrast is the theory of
numbers whole numbers prime numbers
arithmetic operations modular prime
numbers - teen equations and then
something that I will try explain
there's a movie about the proof of
Fermat's Last Theorem where the
interviewer goes to each of these
experts and ask can you explain what a
modular form is and nobody tries except
Barry Mazur who seems to pull it off I
will try to do and probably fail like
everybody in that movie if you haven't
seen it before that is but I'll give you
some feel what they are and they and why
they special and in probability theory
which people have I think much better
intuition about their random objects but
the relevant ones for the theory of
numbers or random geometries random
matrices random polynomials random walks
on groups and even percolation and in
probability theory you you look for
universal laws like the Gaussian and the
topic is to try explain the row
and interplay between number theory and
probability theory so I want to put
forth a dichotomy which in the theory of
numbers this obviously will have
exceptions within the theory of numbers
either a problem has some rigid
structure often not very clear what it
is but when you find it you certainly
know you found it or the answers very
difficult to determine it looks like
it's random and I'm going to give you
examples of this and then the idea would
be that you try to prove that randomness
has kicked in and that turns out to be
much harder than proving structure we
good at occasionally understanding some
structural things so the randomness
feature can be quite unexpected the
distribution might be from somewhere
else where you weren't expecting and
that would be very telling establishing
such a law is usually the very issue so
sometimes when the law is obvious so
it's the central limit theorem clearly
in action then it's just a matter of
establishing it for some something which
is very explicit and there are
implications in both directions so if
you of course understand the law you'll
understand the properties a phenomenon
that you're looking at very well and the
fact that explicit arithmetic Daiya
fantine problem can behave very randomly
it can be a source of something very
useful so in the old days there's hardly
used to had some there's a standard
quote of Hardy here that says that
number theory is that the field a gas to
gas Vietnam bethere is the queen of
mathematics Hardy felt that mathematics
is being used very badly during second
first and second world war and the one
subject that will never be used is
number theory of course he didn't
predict the internet and the computer
and so predictions are very dangerous
from that type oh and from that point of
view we could ask about producing
pseudo-random numbers that would be
obviously the starting point of making
something random through a number theory
but I want to start with something
that's even more basic so let's take the
number pi which i think is about led to
so many decimal places but if I gave
this lecture on pi day maybe somebody
complaining somewhere is pi normal a
normal numbers a number which has the
right number of digits that a random
number should have so the number of ones
in its decimal expansion should be one
tenth of them the number of two should
be one tenth of it and there's no doubt
that if you look at the statistics of
the expansion of pi it's random it's
normal we have no idea how to attack of
such a problem so this is my I'm going
to give four examples of what I'm
talking about them anymore I'm gonna
give four and the first one is this is
PI normal we know so little that I and
under anybody who even would try attack
this problem the kind of thing we know
is we can prove some little iota of
randomness meaning we know the expansion
is not periodic it's not completely
structured in other words pi is
irrational we also know something much
deeper
it's transcendental it doesn't satisfy
any polynomial equation with integer
coefficients as one of the finest
achievements in mathematics by Linderman
stall one of the finest achievements so
the kind of thing that we can't prove
about pi is this little iota towards
showing that it's a random number and
even that is it considered as I say a
major achievement alright so I'm going
to leave that because I have nothing to
say about it except that clearly this
you will see features like this we left
something is at random and then the
whole thing is to try to find methods to
show things at random and Paul Khan was
referring to that he said when we prove
something we really have to have some
structure in order to make a conclusion
it's very hard to prove something is
random like nobody knows how to make
anything that's genuinely random as you
know all right so my second example is
the main is I'll have three more
examples and the second one is a large
chunk of the lecture and it'll be about
primes and quadratic - teen equations
and arithmetic the randomness in
arithmetic but let me start with primes
so the randomness that Cohen was saying
when he was saying the primes look like
they random well let's just remind
ourselves what Prime's are their numbers
which are only divisible by themselves
and one
number one we don't consider to be a
prime and there's a standard way of
making a table the server with pasta
knees where you multi look at the first
number two is prime and you strike out
the multiples of two you look at three
threes prime you strike at the multiples
of three in fact it would be better if I
struck out here with multiplicity and
then I could ask a question that will
come a little later but I was a little
lazy so I just struck out what I struck
out and what's left behind other Prime's
and those are the primes and you look at
them and mankind has looked at this and
every mathematician from a certain older
generation from oil to gas have all made
statements that we don't and in turn
Herman vile that we don't understand the
randomness in the prime numbers there's
no sort of where's the next prime going
to come what do we know about it but
they are structured in other way we made
a construction of them is very simple
the twin primes that Cohens mentioned or
numbers which differ by two and while
there is been progress on this kind of
problem we're so very very far away from
twin prime because there's a fundamental
difficulty they're connected with what's
called parity and I'll describe this
parity to you but later so it does as
how as Cohen says it does look rather
difficult to prove the twin Prime in our
present understanding but I'm not that
person mistake as he is about anything
like this all right so those are the
primes are they random was structured
let's let me remind you what the prime
number theorem is so you could ask how
many Prime's are there less than a
number X so take an integer X how many
Prime's are there less than X so that is
usually denoted by PI of X that pi is
not that pi so you could ask how big is
pi of x when X gets big and there is the
first approximation which is one of the
achievements of the 19th century and
that is that as X goes to infinity PI of
X is roughly X divided by log X the
infinitely many Prime's in there density
is roughly 1 over log X and that's the
famous prime number theorem by the way
in this lecture
not gonna give credit to anybody they
will have a slide at the end which is
credits that's a that's an unusual we're
proceeding in math but let me do it that
way otherwise it would take some of my
time alright so that's a prime number
theorem and I want to explain to you the
difference between what I view as a
structured problem and a random problem
so let me take an odd prime P a large
think of a very large odd prime P we
know there are many of them now and let
me take the following some called the
Gauss sum so it's the sum of e to the 2
pi now the exponential is just a
trigonometric function e to the 2 pi of
an integer is 1 so when I write the sum
down from x equals 0 to P minus 1 I'm
summing over all the X's the only thing
that's important is the remainder of
that fraction when I divide by P so it's
going to be very important so let me
spend a second on that if I look at the
remainders of integers when I divide by
a prime number P and this does use
there's a prime number I look at just
what remainders you get I can do the
same arithmetic that you normally do you
can add numbers and you can multiply
numbers and just keep the remainders and
they satisfy the usual rules that you're
familiar with in arithmetic and you can
even invert numbers and that's
equivalent to P being a prime and so
this forms what's called a finite field
and what gas is writing down there is
the sum of complex numbers they are P of
them e to the 2 pi of something real is
of modulus 1 so you're adding P numbers
if they were random and this is going to
be important this is my first connection
with the random if I add n numbers which
are modulus 1 and they random they
should cancel to about square root n so
the size of that sum you might expect to
be square root in size it's an easy
exercise to square G and collect terms
and you'll find that G squared is P so G
is in fact in absolute value square root
P in size o minus P depending on whether
P gives remainder 1 when divided by 4
with a P gives remainder 3 so this was
well known and gas
was very interested as were many other
people in which sign is the square root
is G plus square root of P or is it
minus square root of P and in the case
that piece congruent to 3 mod 4 is that
I times root P or minus I times root P
there are 2 square roots of a number and
the sign of the Gauss sum is something
he worked out and if you think that he
didn't think this was important this is
what he writes about it to his friend
William Olbers and his correspondent
LeBlanc who secretly Sophie Germain who
had been studying his work and who did
some remarkable work herself she went
under a pseudonym and he says that is
this shortcoming he's talking about
trying to compute he said that he was
what he was trying to do in his this
question arithmetic I which is his main
book on number theory what he was trying
to do he achieved and I'll show you what
he achieved in a minute it's one of the
great theorems that we try to emulate
generalizations of anyway he'd proved
that but along the way there's a
question of what it's which square root
is that Gauss um and I've looked at this
he says the hardly a week has passed
unit lost for years where I haven't made
an attempt in vain to untie that not
especially vigorously during recent time
but all of this brooding and searching
in vain sadly I'd put pin the pin down
again finally if he days ago it has been
achieved but not by my cumbersome search
rather through God's good grace I'm
tempted to say I delight as lightning
strikes and he carries on and he marbles
that he finally computed the sign of the
Gauss um however my astronomical work
should not be completely neglected at
this time in other words at the same
time he was developing his worship
astronomy and Gaussian distributions of
heavenly bodies and this to him was
still a hobby maybe but you can see the
joy with which he found the structure
that's a structured answer if you go and
you experiment with it you'll find the
which square root it is but proving it
is by no means easy it's very closely
connected now you don't need to know it
to prove this theorem to his famous
reciprocity so this is a good example of
what I mean by structure so if you take
two prime numbers which are give
remainder one by when divided by four
both if I look at arithmetic mod P and
arithmetic mod Q there's a fields and I
can ask where the P has got a square
root modulo Q in that field and that's
if and only if Q has a square root
modulo P this is highly non obvious it
was known experimentally before gas gas
was the first to prove it and there are
many proofs today and they are the kind
of thing that drives subjects so across
field theory is a subject in number
theory which is of a grand
generalization of this in the grandest
of all generalizations of the
reciprocity is called Langlands
reciprocity in the theory of automatic
forms which I said I will try to find
for you one example all right so that's
an example of the gas wanting to find
the square root I should say that if you
take the cubes e to the 2 pi X cubed
rather than x squared then there is no
formula for the sign and they are random
and that was first disconnected but the
first realization of what that they
random was when von Neumann was running
his maniac computer with goldstein in
the 50s in Princeton checking what the
signs of cubical sums are and they all
random and that was proved in the 70s
that they are random these ecwid
distributed just the simplest version of
random so this is something very special
the sign of a quadratic Qasim all right
let me stick to arithmetic mod P because
that's a place where we'll see
randomness kick in so suppose I advance
through the numbers X from 1 up to P
then X inverse exists so 1 inverse is 1
2 inverse is P minus 1 over 2 but
quickly you don't know where X inverse
is and it seems to jump around randomly
and if you look at it numerically the
map X to X inverse modulo P if P is a
very large number looks very much like a
random involution of a set of P elements
numerically
so the arithmetic operation of inversion
as a when you look at them we first
order them by linearly and then look at
the inverses the inverse seemed to come
down randomly and the way one measure of
whether that's true is to take the
correlation between a is just a
parameter there so I look at X mod P and
then I look at X inverse mod P and
exponential and if they don't know about
each other then they should be random
numbers of modulus one and that should
cancel to about square root of P I'll
keep on coming back to that theme now si
P has no easy formula unlike the Gauss
um there's no easy besides is not root P
but the deepest theorem in this subject
is that that's less than equal to two
times root P so and and that's a sharp
mount so it's clearly not quite random
because random numbers don't cancel to
exactly square root N and they get a
little bit bigger than square root n
there's a law of large numbers but they
have this feature and this is already
something very deep this follows from
something called the Riemann hypothesis
which is a theorem it's an analogue of
the real Riemann hypothesis which I'll
describe to you I will not describe this
Riemann hypothesis but it's a example of
the Riemann hypothesis showing
something's random in some statistic so
that's a very deep fact that that's at
most two root P and the fact that the
numbers when you take them from 1 to P
that the inverse is a random or
something that can be exploited and have
been exploited heavily they sue they are
source of pseudo-random constructions
and since one of the things that's
discussed in this polynomial yeah I'll
return to that in a minute is Ramanujan
graphs let me give you examples of these
so in computer science there are graphs
that are called expander graphs they are
highly connected but very sparse graphs
the fact that something could be highly
connected and sparse at the same time is
obviously extremely they fight each
other and it's obviously useful if you
want to connect things with few wires or
you are trying to do some other
efficient construction
so let me give you a construction and my
intuition is why this construction works
Israeli because the operations of
arithmetic or random as I just described
and you need this division you need the
operation which is a division which was
X goes to 1 over X and you'll see it
happening here with 2 by 2 matrices so
I'll take a number a large prime number
which is 1 mod xx you might say gee how
do I know there many Prime's which give
remainder 1 when divided by xx that's
something we understand there was many
such crimes as they should be and I'll
take such a prime and then I compute the
square root of -1 by the way that can be
done quickly i compute the square root
of -1 y is the square root of -1 well
that reciprocity theorem of gauss tells
me and i choose one of the square roots
i'll call it i and then i compute the
square root of 5 there's a square root
of 5 modulo P for the same reason that
Gauss gave us that reciprocity and now
write down 6 matrices 1 of Beta Beta is
that square root either of the square
roots of 5 times this 2 by 2 matrix
whose entries are in arithmetic modulo P
I have 6 matrices written down there
explicitly now take all the matrices 2
by 2 matrices of determinant 1 if you
check if I multiply this out and divided
by beta the determinant of that will be
1 under those matrices all have
determinant 1 and the product of two
matrices of determinant 1 is determinant
1 and this is a finite set of matrices
of determinant 1 and it goes by a very
fancy name SL to the two-by-two matrices
of determinant 1 with entries in this
finite arithmetic so they're about P
cubed such matrices and now I'm gonna
make for you a explicit fantastic graph
I'm going to join each matrix in the 2
by 2 matrices to 6 neighbors where I
multiply that matrix by these 6 matrices
and I get a graph which is 6 regular
meaning each vertex is got 6 guards
coming out of it and this is a graph
which has fantastically strong expansion
properties and there's a basic building
block for many things
that's a three regular Ramanujan growth
there are only finitely many three
regular Ramanujan growths that you can
fit in the plane they get to be they
can't be put in the plane so those
that's the biggest one I know on the
left on the right there this is an
example of the graph I was making for
you over there it's got an arbitrary
number of vertices and it's extremely
highly connected I'm going to show you
what that means in a second so we can
make these graphs very explicitly and
the reason they are they behaving as if
they random in certain senses is because
of this Riemann hypothesis in the
function field all right let me tell you
some of the properties these graphs have
they obey an optimal spectral expansion
so if you measure what you mean by
highly connected these are optimal in
every sense but primarily in the
spectral sense they are the graphs are
not quite they can't be this will be an
indication that we have a mixture where
is a bit of randomness and structure it
is possible to navigate so one of the
consequences of being an expander is
that any two vertices of this graph have
a very short path between them and then
it's quite natural could you find that
short path and the answer is you can
find the shortest path between two
elements in the graph if G and H have
the property that G inverse H is a
diagonal matrix remember mark the
vertices in this graph happened to be
two by two matrices I can ask that
question and so for many of the vertices
there is a algorithm to find the
shortest path on the other hand if you
want to get between any two points
that's np-complete so that shows these
graphs are quite complicated that means
that if you can solve that problem
finding the shortest path in this very
simple Grove between any two points then
you can actually solve any np-complete
problem in fact you can reduce this
problem to what's called the knapsack
problem that Richard Cobb showed in
these very early works on NP
completeness as being one of the
equivalent hard problems
so this is a very simple problem and the
fact that shows shows you there's a lot
of complication yeah because you can't
navigate optimally but you can navigate
three times longer than the optimal
which is makes this extremely useful so
these are examples of randomness in
arithmetic being used to achieve
something which is extremely useful I
want to emphasize again that it's the
Riemann hypothesis that tells you that
every two points have a short path
between them doesn't find you the short
path but it tells you that they are
short and it tells you many other
statistical properties that come from
iein values of certain operators which
are connected with the Riemann
hypothesis the construction that I gave
you there works if you have a six
regular graph and it'll work if you want
to have any graph you can make a similar
construction if the number of vertices
is then a number of elements in a field
plus one a prime power plus one elements
in the finite field plus one so nobody
knew how to make a seven regular
Ramanujan growth of arbitrary large
number of vertices and I would give
lectures and say that without number
theory you'll never do it but you should
never say such things because that was
one of the achievements that led to this
polynomial Xia where ramana John's
graphs of any degree were constructed
and what replaces the Riemann hypothesis
there's a very clean thing that replaces
the Riemann hypothesis is the liang
theorem from statistical physics it's
playing the role of the Riemann
hypothesis which is one ingredient in
the proof and the other big ingredient
in the proof is interlacing polynomials
in hyperbolic polynomials and it's a
combination of those two that allows for
the construction of Ramanujan graphs
bipartite mind you of any degree so
that's a bit of a blow to me because I
would have liked to think the only way
you can do it is with the theory of
numbers apparently that's not true
there's nothing wrong with the number
theory growths they fall better they're
easy to make and you can use it the same
set of ideas by the way which has to do
with the call this has to do with a
rattling - teen equation and the theory
of modular functions allows you to
construct optimal quantum gates so if
anybody ever builds a quantum computer
now I'm not going to put any bets on
whether somebody's in a build a quantum
computer but suppose somebody builds a
quantum computer and you want to
actually write a program and in fact you
can buy a quantum computer from IBM I
understand and it cost one hundred and
thirty thousand dollars and it doesn't
do much but you could be the first owner
of a quantum computer and their program
is written using the gates I'm about to
give you and these gates rely heavily on
the same mathematics and the same
solutions in the same randomness in the
same navigation so the difference
between a classical and quantum computer
in a classical computer every bit is a 0
1 and in a quantum computer a single
qubit is a vector in situ of length 1
and that how you achieve that is of
course another matter but that's the
theoretical side of quantum computing if
you have n bits in a classical computer
just 0 1 to the N in the quantum
computer it's C - 10 set to the N of
these vectors of length 1 and a 1 but
quantum gate the only thing you can do
with a when you're writing a circuit for
a program is you can take a bit and you
can switch it on and off there's not
only one thing you can do and that's one
of the basic operations you should have
in your pocket and it's denoted in
circuit theory with this funny thing
like that in quantum computers because
I'm if I have one qubit when qubit is a
vector of length 2 and if I want to move
it around to another position in order
to write a program I need a 2 by 2
unitary matrix which takes me from a
vector of length 1 to another vector of
length 1 so I must the gates are 2 by 2
unitary matrices which now are 2 by 2
matrices before I had 2 by 2 matrices
which had entries in a finite field now
I have 2 by 2 complex matrices
physicists like to write dagger
mathematicians like to write star a star
a equals I is the definition of the
unitary group and a gate a one qubit
gate is just an element in the unitary
group which presumably people are trying
to build in the laboratory
if all you had was a one cubit you
wouldn't be able to go very far you need
to be able to write a program you need n
qubits but there's a big difference here
in a one ordinary classical bit you can
just switch on and off but in a cubit
there's a continuum of vectors of length
one so if you're going to build a
quantum computer the question is you're
not going to be able to have to get
everywhere because that's a continuum
yeah and you can get into finitely many
positions so the question is you want a
gate set it's called Universal so that
you can approximate any unitary matrix
of size 2 to the N by 2 to the N body's
basic building blocks and the main
difference in this is the one qubit
where if you can already do one qubit
and then add for example here in boolean
arithmetic of brilliant systems you just
add and and not you can write down any
expression and circuit is built out of
that in a quantum computer if you could
if you already knew how to make all one
qubit rotations you just add and this is
what they do in this program in this IBM
program you add this controlled-not
which is a two qubit which you should of
course have to be able to deal with any
two at a time in order to write down a
general guide so a universal gate set
which is for example not an and are in
ordinary a boolean arithmetic the ones
that are used are clifford which i'm
going to show you plus T these are just
one qubits and the C not so the Clifford
happens to be the following set of
matrices which generate you two or P you
tube that's a technical thing optimally
so there's the other mod matrix which is
that two by two matrix the phase matrix
if you take these two matrices which are
two by two matrices and you look at all
matrices you get you just get 24
matrices they are the symmetries of a
cube and that's called the clifford
group and they love that particular
group but if all you had was the
clifford group you wouldn't have a
quantum computer you must be able to get
it everywhere in order to have the power
of a quantum computer so for some reason
I had not been able to find out who
first in this
quantum this is in all the textbooks who
first came up with this tea gate but
they knew they had to add one more gate
to make it dance and they add this gate
T and when you add that gate T you'll
get matrices which you multiply here
you'll get all of something which is
dense in the unitary group and hence
you'll have a universal set and the
remarkable thing is this Universal set
behaves as if it were random meaning it
covers the group optimally fast and you
can navigate just like you can with the
Ramanujan graphs and the mathematics
that goes to do that is all identical
it's all got to do with quaternions and
at this die fantine equation and modular
forms and the Riemann hypothesis this
time the Riemann hypothesis of four
varieties of a finite field is needed to
actually prove these gates are optimal
so the moral of the story is I don't
think anybody's built a quantum computer
if you bought this quantum computer they
run it classically for many things you
have to talk Darleen your program I
think they might run some part quantum
mechanically but if they ever build a
quantum computer these are the optimum
these are a optimal set of gates and the
reason that's working is the randomness
of arithmetic operations and diving team
equations so I hope that shows you that
well the theme that I was trying to say
is that the fact that something's
behaving randomly is a very powerful can
be very powerful to make something
explicit which is looking like it's
random and maybe doing something very
nice all right I now will I have two
more such themes of randomness and
number theory and I haven't explained
the Riemann hypothesis I will bring it
to you in an unusual way so I want to
talk about the parity and I mentioned in
the twin prime problem is a fundamental
stumbling block it's parity the most
difficult thing that we have in the
theory of numbers just prime numbers is
the parity of the number of prime
factors of an integer that's already
quite quite secret that a number keeps
so let's look for randomness in
structure so lambda n will be the parity
of the number of prime factors meaning
whether the number of prime factors
after a factor in into prime powers and
count the number of total number of
prime factors is that even or odd just
to show you that these things can be
subtle suppose our little m the three
and B the parity of nine the parity of
the number prime factors which give
remainder three win divided by four
after a factor and I only look at the
Prime's which give remainder three and
they lambda 1 and the parity of the
prime factors which give remainder 1 win
divided by four all right I have a table
here that you can easily compute for
yourself you just factor each number one
I'm only looking the odd numbers here
for simplicity so I look at 1 3 5 7 9 a
factor 1 1 well 1 is 1 is 1 you know
primes there's a parity 0 so it's the
lambdas 1 3 is the prime and it's a
prime which is congruent to 3 mod 4 so
lambda 3 will be minus 1 while lambda 1
n will be 1 and then you compute this
ignore this for a second this times that
equals that anyway and if you look at
lambda 3 it doesn't take much to see
that there's a pattern just switches
from 1 to minus 1 from 1 to minus 1 so
that's a case of structure that's
staring you in the face
they are variants on this way it's not
so obvious the periodicity of the
sequence might be quite long but we
understand that very well so there
lambda 3 is far from random but lambda 1
which is the number of prime factors
which give remainder 1 when divided by 4
there is no pattern and we believe that
nobody if we'll ever find a pattern and
this is the kind of randomness that is
played we believe it but I'll show you
how hard it is to prove anything towards
that being a random sequence lambda
since lambda 3 is very structured and
lambda 1 I'm trying to say is random so
will lambda n be structured of course if
I know this one I know that one alright
so how do I measure the randomness one
way is to measure self correlations of
lambda with itself lambda n lambda N
plus h but that's the kind of problem
where at the end I'll say we're Paul
Cohen might
saying maybe that's too hard to say and
to actually solve but actually what we
can do is we can try correlate lambda in
against sequences which are low
complexity that is to say if lambdas
very random and if is a very low
complexity sequence and if you're the
Symons Institute low complexity
presumably means computational
complexity but that's not the right
notion as far as I'm concerned because a
it takes you in the wrong direction and
B if I want to believe that that when
I'm saying uncorrelated seriously
uncorrelated mean that the average value
goes to zero would mean that a low
complexity sequence can't mimic the
parity would mean that you can't factor
quickly if you can factor quickly then
we out of business here because I could
take f of n to be lambda of n and if
that if you can factor quickly then
certainly that's not the right notion of
low complexity so I'm a big believer
that you can factor quickly but let me
just leave it at that so the right way
or a better way is to measure the low
complexity dynamically you can measure
complexity of a sequence observed in a
dynamical system by the entropy of the
system and there's a nice conjecture
here which is that lambda is random in
the sense that lambda n times F n will
go to 0 for any deterministic sequence
FN that is one which is of low
complexity in the sense of zero entropy
and there's tremendous progress on this
and I would like to point out that many
hard problems about the theory of primes
involves just showing more randomness in
this conjecture so the sequences for
which you land up proving this
conjecture all zero entropy all
deterministic but they are more complex
there there's the set of such dynamical
systems is very complicated and so each
time you prove a new version of that
you've learnt a little bit more
randomness about lambda so for example
if f of N equals 1 that's the most
deterministic sequence this goes to 0 is
completely equivalent to the
number two and if F of n is rotation
this is something that's used to prove
the every odd numbers of sum of three
primes okay I should tell a joke you
might ask is the prime number is the
twin primes which I even put there is
that an interesting problem well any
high school student who sees that I
don't see any high school students but
that you would recognize that and you
will want to know the answer whether
it's useful or not now I don't think
it's got any use but it is it's a
compelling problem so there's a famous
story of Lev Landau to show you that
this problem from some point of view may
not be so natural
Waveland are very famous mathematical
physicist at the Landau Institute but it
was a stack ruff Institute at the time
asks one of his friends is a young
postdoc why is that guy in a grotto who
was a nasty guy why is he our boss what
did he prove they said oh you don't know
he proved the Goldbach problem for three
primes so he says what's that he says
every odd number is the sum of three
primes
so Landau says what I learned about
primes in high school as I thought
you're supposed to multiply Prime's not
add them it is not a natural problem but
the methods to prove it
they are great so the sum of these
problems and I'll return to them are not
natural the next one is very natural not
maybe not stated this way but stated in
the whale stated in a second and that is
suppose I look for a quantitative
version of the fact that summation
lambda in in up to n I told you is
divided by n goes to zero that's the
prime number theorem
well if lambda n is really random yeah
and you look at little end up to capital
n how many numbers have an odd number of
parity and how many have an even number
the difference should be at mouse square
root n if they were random that's always
the random model and this is total
logically equivalent to what's called
the Riemann hypothesis the real Riemann
hypothesis so it's very easy to describe
the Riemann hypothesis to you it's that
statement and all you have to do is
prove that
but this offers no attack on this
problem and it doesn't look a natural
problem from this other than that parity
is random I think I have to do justice
and tell you what the Riemann hypothesis
is so if you don't know what a complex
function is you can ignore this part so
you have series n to the minus s in the
subject the complex variable is usually
denoted by s naught Z of the Riemann and
this has a analytic continuation and
functional equation it's defined for
real part of s and it's connection to
primes is the unique factorization into
prime so that product is that sum and
riemann discovered this amazing thing
that if you multiply this function by
elementary functions a gamma function
and exponential PI to the minus s over 2
then this function as the functional
equation s into 1 minus s and it may be
not so well known but he checked the
fuses first few zeroes himself I should
say that later people used computers
touring one of the very first one of his
dreams was to show the power of the
computer in disproving the Riemann
hypothesis and riemann computed the
first three Titchmarsh by hand maybe the
first 10 and then he had some lot of
people work for him to compute up to
about a hundred and of course Turing
could go to a few thousand and today we
know the first as Paul Cohen said the
first 10 to the 10 are on the line 1/2
and so we write the zeroes as 1/2 plus I
gamma and we find them the first 0 is
very high up this was a very painful
thing for Riemann let's say he struggled
to find it actually so the question from
my point of view of randomness is what
do these zeros behave like do they
behave as if God is throwing down random
numbers there or maybe there's a much
more telling distribution so this is
what I was telling you that occasionally
the distribution is quite shocking it's
coming from somewhere else and it turns
out if you look at the zeros of there
there's no formula so maybe they're
random and it turns out they are random
numerically they follow perfectly they
get the rules of Gaussian unitary
ensemble they the the spacing
distribution of the large n by n unitary
matrices when n goes to infinity this
seems to be a perfect match
numerically it suggests is very
suggestive that the eigenvectors Eros
are some icon values or energy levels
which of course is something that
inspires people to think about how you
might interpret them and how you might
prove this hypothesis it turns out that
the zeros of any elf function follow
this universal rule and one can in this
function field setting prove everything
so one can understand where that comes
from and that's because in this function
field setting thanks to the work of
growth and ik one does have a spectral
interpretation of the zeros that is very
useful for those are real experts it
turns out they aren't three families of
matrices goe GU e and g se as Dyson has
suggested they actually ten families of
random matrices that are correspond to
codons ten families of symmetric spaces
and only four of them come up in number
theory and we understand why at least in
the function field he has the ten to the
sixteenth zero and its many Neil and its
billion zeros nearby and the consecutive
spacing between them follows this gue
distribution which is not easy to
compute Vigna couldn't compute it it
actually is a pain Levay five this fits
perfectly in physics where this question
was raised by Vigna the the data is so
bad that they even have the wrong
distribution and they don't even know it
because their data is it's there's
another distribution called the Vigna
sohmas which is one hundredth away from
this and it's good enough in practice
but we're not let's go who was computing
this with their zeroes of zeta for the
first time needed to know it exactly he
needed the exact solution of what that
curve is and this kind of fit is plenty
good so the moral here is that the
distribution of the zeroes is very much
random but it's not random numbers it's
random matrices and that's something we
don't know how to exploit but it has to
be a clue to something all right now I
have still five eight minutes I want to
explain that modular forms
which were used in some of the things
that was saying or something very
unusual it's hard to explain why they so
useful and they allow you to solve
problems like for Mars lost theorem and
many other things and it really is a
paper that's missing in the literature
there's a famous paper
Wigner called the unreasonable
effectiveness of mathematics in physics
and somebody has to write the paper the
unreasonable effectiveness of modular
forms in number theory and I want to
explain to you that one reason I think
they are so special is they violate my
dichotomy there many other things that
probably also do but they handsomely
violated that is they are neither random
no structured they are really mixture of
both they're both the rigid and random
features they cannot written be written
down explicitly yet you can calculate
with them to the better end so you
calculate can calculate things that you
should not really be allowed to
calculate using something called the
trace formula and that is what's used in
the solution of many many problems so
they violate this principle they I've
got a complexity which allows you to
show randomness from structure and it's
exactly that feature that allows you to
get your foot in the door
what are these modular forms there are
simply vibrational modes of rigid
membranes or geometries I'll give you
one example now that's what they are
there are vibrational modes they satisfy
certain differential equations on
certain rigid geometries so a good
example is just the simplest one instead
of having Euclidean space and periodic
functions like sine and cosine that
everybody understands we get functions
that are that much more complicated
modular functions because they have
periodicity and there's something much
more much richer so we take the upper
half-space
all complex numbers with imaginary part
positive and instead of having the
geometry be the only euclidean geometry
in other words the distance between two
infinitesimal distances DZ we
/ why and this makes the space into the
upper plane into a console into a
homogeneous space of curvature exactly -
one as Gauss knew the shortest distance
between any two points is a geodesic
which if the two points are on a
vertical line it's that or if two points
are on a hemisphere semicircle they're
that two points have a unique semicircle
which goes through them that would be
the geodesic between them so this is an
infinite space and the big difference
between Euclidean space where you have
the group of motions is just translation
basically here the group of motions are
these two by two matrices or in general
n by n matrices with integer entries
which act isometrically they preserve
this in the action which is got division
in it like I was saying in the finite
field Z goes to AZ plus B over C Z plus
D so when you take this group and you
take the whole space and you identify
points which are the same orbit you get
a space and the vibrating modes on that
space or the automatic forms so they
satisfy these differential equations and
from a certain point of view another
reason why order morphic forms sort of
defies principles is that if you were
playing billiards in a rectangle
ordinary rectangle you know exactly
where the billiard would go off the long
time but if you play billiards in this
triangle which is what this quotient
looks like with the jit with emotion
being these geodesics that I just
described this billiard motion is very
chaotic so the fact that you can take a
chaotic system and actually write down
the eigenfunctions in some form not
explicitly but in some form indirectly
learning something is what allows you to
conclude precious information that no
other mathematics seems to be able to do
so so far we don't have any other proof
of Fermat's Last Theorem for example and
many many other theorems here's a
typical vibrational mode and I was going
to explain to you what's random
I'm running out of time so I'll just say
that what you do when you have a
vibrational mode is you there's a
symmetry here which is clear in in this
picture but otherwise you can count how
many of these nodal domains are there
for such a vibrating triangle arithmetic
triangle and it turns out that the
randomness here is the same as
monochromatic wave so this is a theory
of probability we're actually the Pro
Bowlers have not understood this problem
yet how many what's the zero set of a
random nodal domain or of random
algebraic geometry but these things are
now being answered in probability theory
and my interest in this is greatly
enhanced by the fact that the modular
forms obey this randomness and this is
all numerical and of course just like
with PI or with like the prime number
theorem what we can prove is a little
iota of that and we're very happy with
that so when this is a random spherical
harmonic it's supposed to look like that
and it does so there's the randomness of
that model and using the most advanced
tools here we can show that the number
of nodal domains in this problem goes to
infinity with the frequency I should say
that Hunt slavey who was one of the
great PDE guys in this department at
Berkeley in last century one of his very
last theorems was to show that if you
take the sphere is it sphere yeah and
you look at a spherical harmonic you can
make a sequence of eigenmodes
which has only three nodal domains so
it's not true that the number of nodal
domains goes to infinity because of
partial differential equations it's
because of randomness and the modular
forms are behaving perfectly random and
there's even a percolation theory that
seems to be obeyed by them so that's
where probability theory is getting to
be already quite advanced in
understanding these all right so let me
conclude and go back to Paul Cohen so
firstly I've been talking about
randomness and establishing the
randomness to non-structured number
theoretic problems is usually very
difficult and we are happy to prove that
pi is Arash
or Pie's transcendental and similarly
here we're happy to prove that some
randomness feature like square root
cancellation in the function field is
very powerful that and in the number of
in the case of lambda n we stuck so this
and and in terms of applications there's
no question about the use of these cut
this kind of number theory on the other
hand I agree completely with Paul Cohen
that most problems that we pose in
number theory and probably in other
parts of mathematics will never be
answered but I absolutely don't share
his pessimism because I think that
mathematicians are very good at sifting
out what the fundamental problems are so
people raise problems and the ones that
are not approachable and not interesting
disappear but the ones which are
approachable get solved that gets added
to our lovely subject and then
occasionally these real important
problems for which anybody in the
trenches is working on these problems
are not worried about what can or cannot
be proved you might be burnt
occasionally those problems are believe
we have a great knack of singling out
those problems that actually will be
solved so twin primes I'm sure will be
solved by the way I want to make another
joke here is Sarah whose gives fantastic
lectures I heard him give a lecture a
few years ago in Princeton where he was
explaining the twin prime problem is
unnatural but then he said I'm motivated
and it took me about two minutes to
realize his joke non motivic that's for
mathematicians it's a non motivic
problem and motivated he certainly
thinks the problem is a great problem I
have no doubt it will be solved the
parity problem is what's keeping us away
from it but it will be solved and I
should say Cohen himself who put a
tremendous effort to the Riemann
hypothesis on most days certainly
believe that the Riemann hypothesis
itself
is something that certainly will be
solved so our subject is very far from
drying up the way he said I don't take
his pessimistic view in fact we are all
very privileged to live in the golden
era where some remarkable theorems have
been
proved it is the golden era of
mathematics thank you yeah yeah
absolutely
so the proof there are thousands of
theorems that say assume the Riemann
hypothesis in a somewhat generalized
form and then they imply something and
what that thing may imply is something
very interesting very fundamental and
usually the step that the Riemann
hypothesis has achieved for you is some
randomness establishment or some control
that you wouldn't have otherwise but
usually with some which if it were
random would be easily handled and so
the answer is in terms of mathematics
there's no question about its use but in
terms of its outside use just like the
function field there's I can give you
many many many so one reason the Riemann
hypothesis sticks out as a problem as
opposed to almost any other problem is
it's a truth that's so powerful that
unlike the twin prime I don't know any
use of that it's just you've got to
answer that question how can you not
answer that question but the Riemann
hypothesis is also a powerful
fundamental truth about numbers and it's
really saying there is no unexpected
behavior that we don't know it's really
saying that that parity is random it's
equivalent to Riemann hypothesis it's
just that's not the way to attack it in
my view I mean I should tell you I get
at the annals six proofs of Riemann each
week I have to spend a good few hours
just rejecting these but 99.9 can be
rejected on the basis of a certain thing
which I'll keep them in mind it's part
of my ammunition and then there's a ones
that ok I'll look at it later and then
that poor
both away has to wait for a long time so
the answer is it's an unusual I don't
know of any other problem that has such
a truth such a ringing truth that so
many other things follow so it does but
it doesn't say anything unexpected it
says there's nothing unexpected that we
haven't there no correlations there's no
structure if you know the number if you
have a number in a very larger number
you have no idea where it's got an even
or odd number of prime factors if it's
got an even number of prime factors then
you say well there's the next one have
some does that condition the next one to
look something no answer is no we don't
believe that and that's what it's saying
and proving something is random as Paul
Cohen said he was dissecting skull lumps
method saying well all you do is this
and then how you gonna prove many
theorems probably you won't prove many
theorems but the way we win is those
little miracles where the problem is
somehow natural and wants to be solved
because you have to believe in your
heart that these problems are solvable
Cohen did this was a bad day when he
wrote it it was you get late in your
life and you want to explain why you
failed little would also by the way
little would enlighten his life started
saying the Riemann hypothesis is false
I'm sure it's just simply because he
couldn't do it there's no good reason to
believe it's false yeah
yeah yeah so this is a very good thing
when Li and yang proved their theorem in
statistical physics that the zeroes of a
certain easing partition function have
all its zeros on a circle and the
function field when it Riemann
hypothesis when it as it's normally
stated it's about a function it's a
better polynomial all of whose zeros lie
on a circle so it read it looks and mark
cats and Polya immediately thought this
this clearly is somehow related to rima
the trouble with this liang theorem and
you it's proved by a method which
there's no way you're gonna prove the
Riemann hypothesis because the method is
by first Li it's constructed inductively
there many proofs but one of the unusual
thing is to count the number of zeroes
and show that they hold on the circle
you can see sign changes for example
there's a version that's used in this
construction by Leoben Hellman of this
Liang though anyway that theorem and the
connection I see it very clearly I don't
know that
Nikhil sees it identify he's yeah even
but the way it's used is in the
construction where they prove something
called Ballou's conjecture and lineal
and Baloo's conjecture is they take all
double covers which are all plus minus
ones of a graph and they look at all the
double covers and I want to show that
there's at least one double cover which
is Ramanujan and then repeatedly take
double covers that's that's proof that's
how they make make construction so the
first step is to take the expected value
of all double covers and you take this
expected value of all double covers and
you get a polynomial and that polynomial
has all its roots on a circle just like
the Riemann hypothesis I know in in the
construction the number theoretic
construction I know exactly where the
Riemann is used and it's used heavily
and it's putting all the zeroes on the
circle so in this other argument you
take the the average value of these
characteristic polynomial
and that has the property cuz of a liang
through then you want to show that at
least one of those has it's all its gaza
interval and that's where the
interlacing enough all this hyperbolic
polynomial stuff enters beautifully so
they're two parts in the proof in the
one part to me is identical so i don't
see any connection between the riemann
hypothesis and the liang theorem but
there's enough of a connection that the
liang theorem and the riemann hypothesis
are the source of the key property in
the two constructions yeah
very few near hundreds more days
and we seem to forget that very quickly
well most conjectures in Die Fantine
equations are based on ignorance meaning
we only know how to make integer points
irrational points and in those
situations people have to keep modifying
them as people find the examples so it's
very dangerous when you say or add all
of these there usually those mistakes um
those false things are somebody has some
structure they prove something and then
a conjecture it's true universally and
then I know some examples that I was
involved with disproving but I don't
want to mention the name sir and
otherwise I'm blanking on big failures
of conjectures you know who dodged
remarkably who made millions and
millions of conjectures of which many
might fall into this category of not
solvable but he's great talent and this
is an immense talent is he always a
usually is right sometimes wrong but
usually right but he knows how to put it
just out of reach so that you become
addicted and so that you say oh wait I
can do that and most of these
conjectures that I know I mean I there's
so many of them that but every now and
then somebody will come and give a talk
and say I've solved this conjecture of -
worth $2,000 and that gives you some
clue of how difficult it was anyway his
great ability was I think to find truths
which are epsilon away from what
actually can be done and require a new
idea to solve it so enriches the field
in that way but I've had a lot of
criticism about that of kind of
mathematics in fact Cohen would
criticize that kind of you know hundreds
of different problems and but like math
competition
so I think that in terms of the main
problems we've mathematicians are very
good yet sifting out kicking it around
and then what remains and we've seen
from as Lawson but we've seen something
even greater the proof of the Ponca
right conjecture we live in a very
special time
[Applause]
yeah